in the next few days I don't know I just  yes I just heard this today myself I  call performance hungry artist yeah  because I was hungry and I just taste  for like $120,000 I mean it tasted  regular mud banana again of course but I  was very happy I did this because I  think what artists have to do the mask  to make happy people and less must  people make enjoy what you do and this  is what I did I know hired this is the  first time I see this PR and I just had  a talk to see the art and I use the pure  edges before like five seven years ago  but now it's not about PR and like this  is what the gallery told me it's about  PR but I already have PR I'm like  Smithsonian recognized artist and I know  need PR you know first of all I did this  because I want to do it second if people  want to ask me why I have happy to be  one